BOOM!
On May 12, 2588, the town of Kangaatsiaq,
Greenland, was destroyed by a devastating
four-kiloton explosion accompanied by a massive
electromagnetic pulse.
The few survivors that made it through the
incident alive described seeing a "pale green
light" in the area at the time of the explosion.
Shortly after, a ΩK/A-class scenario (or
"end of death" scenario) began, in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to experience
a regenerative effect regardless of injury
or illness.
In other words, nobody could die anymore.
This resulted in intense, worldwide panic
in the face of the inexplicable occurrence.
As the panic mounted, the O5 council of the
SCP Foundation held an emergency meeting in
order to address the possibilities at hand.
Meanwhile, civilians began reporting sightings
of a giant, pale white humanoid monster rampaging
through their cities and communities, wreaking
havoc and violently attacking anyone and anything
in its path.
As the situation progressed and worsened,
and the reality of the End-of-Death scenario
began to set in, the SCP Foundation made the
difficult decision to lift its veil of secrecy,
and reveal itself to the world.
O5-1 made a statement to the UN regarding
the reality of the worldwide anomaly, advising
citizens to remain calm and await further
instructions.
Five days after the world learned the truth
about the SCP Foundation, the pale monster
arrived in St. John's, Newfoundland, where
it was met by Mobile Task Force Nu-7 "Hammer
Down" for what they hoped would be a quick
fight and neutralization.
Instead, two years of devastating, bloody
combat ensued.
By July 4, 2590, 90% of the task force personnel
had been killed and regenerated an average
of five times.
At this point, MTF Nu-7 abandoned the city
of St. John, citing "anomalously poor working
conditions".
After being held in place for two years, the
monster was able to break through the defensive
line and continue its rampage.
On October 10, 2590, the SCP Foundation and
the Global Occult Coalition came together
in an act of unprecedented cooperation to
found Project Beluga, dedicated to the goal
of neutralizing the monster, designated SCP-UBU,
and stopping its reign of terror.
But Project Beluga was unable to neutralize
the entity before it reached Columbus, Ohio,
on December 29, 2590.
Once it arrived in the city, SCP-UBU began
dedicating its time to a gruesome personal
project.
First, it dug a two-kilometer-deep hole in
the city's center.
Next, it gathered a total of 2.9 million civilians,
throwing them into the hole.
After the hole was full, the entity leaped
into the upper stratosphere over and over
again, stomping into the hole each time.
When the people inside were pulverized, the
entity destroyed a large fountain, which it
used as a cup, and drank the resulting juices
from the hole.
This entire process took roughly one year,
and when it was finished, the entity appeared
to grow bored with Columbus, and moved to
Lake Erie.
Upon reaching Lake Erie, SCP-UBU trudged out
into the water and began assaulting the cargo
ships docked there.
It began lifting ships up and throwing them
out of the water, some flying high enough
to exit Earth's gravitational pull altogether.
Two of the ships were later spotted on the
surface of the Moon.
This chaos and destruction continued for years
and years, until June 10, 2670, when SCP-UBU
was contained at SCP Foundation Site-59.
However, this containment only lasted for
two minutes, at which point the entity escaped
and made its way to New York City, where it
was found howling and attempting to defile
the Statue of Liberty.
Several countries used their nuclear arsenals
to attack SCP-UBU over the course of its rampage,
until the Schenectady Agreement was signed
on February 10, 2674, cementing an agreement
between NATO powers, the Russian Federation,
the People's Republic of China, and the Global
Occult Coalition.
All signatories agreed that, due to concerns
around the environment, any additional nuclear
strikes against the entity would be prohibited.
After the signing was finished, SCP-UBU crashed
the ceremony, grabbing several lengths of
rebar and fifteen foreign dignitaries, which
it used to construct itself a bead necklace.
The next notable incident occurred when SCP-UBU
showed up at Site-19, interrupting a round
of testing with SCP-AFF - A woman capable
of turning matter into stone by speaking to
it.
SCP-UBU broke through the ceiling, crushing
AFF beneath its weight.
SCP-682, which was also present, approached
the entity curiously, and SCP-UBU responded
by angrily defecating, and shouting at SCP-682
in gibberish.
SCP-682 seemed to understand this vocalization,
and attacked SCP-UBU, demanding that it take
back the insult.
At this point, SCP-UBU slapped 682's cheek,
causing 682 to let out a horrific scream.
The slap left behind a glowing green mark,
which spread over the entirety of 682's body
before breaking the bonds of its cells all
at once, dissolving the reptile into a pool
of toxic fluid.
SCP-UBU then spent five minutes bathing in
this fluid while giggling.
After finishing its bath, devouring the reconstituted
SCP-AFF, and screaming into the microphone
for twenty minutes, SCP-UBU broke into Armed
Containment Area-179 and swallowed SCP-2317
whole.
On March 5, 2686, SCP-UBU conducted an assault
on Thaumiel Class SCP-2000, rendering it "neutralized."
Again, years of hell passed as Project Beluga
struggled to come up with new methods that
had not already been exhausted.
Meanwhile, civilians did their best to find
ways to cope with the state of the world.
On March 25, 2750, former film star Nash De
Groot published "the Zonk Manifesto," a book
based around a simple principle: Life on Earth
was no longer worth living consciously, and
the only way forward was to enter an eternal
coma through the combination of chemicals
and guided meditation.
This kickstarted the social movement, "The
International Zonk."
On June 24, 2790, Project Beluga forces managed
to drive SCP-UBU into the Bay of Bengal, where
it remained for three years, causing very
little trouble aside from underwater seismic
events.
Meanwhile, the International Zonk continued
to grow, and one mass of adherents known as
Cuddletopia reached its goal of five million
residents.
On July 10, 2793, SCP-UBU flung SCP-3000 out
of the ocean, leaving it beached on the soil
of India.
Several cities were destroyed in this process.
The entity then spent a week pointing and
laughing at the beached sea monster, before
grabbing it by the tip of its tail and beginning
to drag it across Asia.
SCP-UBU continued carving a path through Asia,
the wriggling SCP-3000 in tow, until it reached
the Bering Strait.
Then, it began to cross the Strait into Alaska,
returning to North American territory once
more.
But it didn't stop there, instead advancing
toward South America until it, and SCP-3000,
arrived on the eastern coast of Brazil on
August 29, 2793.
There, it dragged its unfortunate charge back
into the ocean once more, disappearing from
sight.
On August 30, 2793, SCP-169, or The Leviathan,
emerged from the depths of the ocean.
There are some reports that SCP-3000 had been
"tied around its neck" but these have not
been confirmed.
The Leviathan and SCP-UBU then entered into
a lengthy battle which carried on for several
hundred years.
After so much time had passed that witnesses
could scarcely remember a time when it wasn't
happening, the fight between SCP-UBU and SCP-169
came to a halt.
Much as it had with SCP-682, SCP-UBU slapped
SCP-169 across the face with such force that
its cell bonds dissolved, and it melted into
a puddle of fluid, which was lost beneath
the ocean waves.
SCP-169 was reclassified "neutralized."
December 11, 3020 marked the start of a ten-year
period of inactivity for SCP-UBU.
Ordinarily, one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief.
However, even in spite of the global immortality,
the collateral damage from SCP-UBU's centuries
of carnage had rendered the surface of the
earth uninhabitable, with all land now underwater.
The remains of human civilization persist
on a single archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris.
Meanwhile, the International Zonk movement
has persisted, gaining more and more traction
and popularity as conscious life became less
and less bearable.
An enormous floating Zonk Pile, consisting
of International Zonk followers using anomalous
methods to achieve "the perfect Zonk," began
to form.
Eventually, this pile earned the nickname
"New Zonkland."
By May 28, 3028, the Archipelago was abandoned,
and the 140 remaining conscious humans retreated
to the SCP Foundations SCPS Naismith.
There, they lived in relative safety for several
months, until SCP-UBU was spotted in the water
off the port bow of the Naismith on January
14, 3030.
It emitted several sounds that witnesses described
as "mocking," before swimming off toward New
Zonkland.
In response to this reappearance after ten
years of inactivity, the O5 Council called
an emergency meeting.
The transcript for this meeting reads as follows:
O5-11: We haven't exhausted all of our anomalous
options for neutralizing UBU.
Where's the Corncrake?
O5-2: We've been over this, Laurence!
Throwing the Corncrake in this mess is only
going to -
O5-4: It's anchored 57 klicks due southeast.
O5-2: …Four, why the hell did you tell him
that?
O5-11: Well, friends?
It seems the Omega-K has had us up and about
so long that our personalities have run out
of the fuel we were given from birth.
In all likelihood, we'd see better professionalism
and teamwork in New Zonkland.
O5-2: …as a matter of fact, that's a good
segue into what I was about to propose.
O5-11: Then frankly, I hope you find the nicest,
cleanest spots in the mass grave.
O5-1: Where are you going?!
O5-11: That depends, which way is southeast?"
At this point, O5-11 left the room, presumably
to track down the Corncrake, leaving the remains
of the O5 council there, and leaving the remains
of Project Beluga with the question of how
to handle SCP-UBU.
According to its official SCP Foundation file,
SCP-UBU is an extremely violent and hostile
humanoid entity of unknown origin, which appeared
in Greenland on May 12, 2588.
It displays anomalous physical strength and
speed, as well as reality-bending capabilities
and the emission of regenerative lambda waves
linked to an ongoing End-Of-Death Scenario.
The appearance of SCP-UBU, and the start of
the End-of-Death scenario, coincided with
several additional phenomena.
There was a mass loss of function for all
the objects operated by the Three Moons Initiative.
The Three Moons Initiative was an extradimensional
human organization based in SCP-2922-C, or
the afterlife known as Corbenic.
This organization was founded 14,000 years
ago with the purpose of establishing a human
colony in the afterlife, and has long maintained
a peace treaty with the SCP Foundation.
SCP-2922, a method of communication that allowed
a human mind to make calls to any pre-established
phone number, ceased all functions.
Next, the extradimensional space known as
the Wanderer's Library, a magical archive
of all of the knowledge from all known worlds,
and every book that has ever been written,
will be written, and several that have not
and will not exist, was severed from Earth.
When the SCP Foundation pressed the Serpent's
Hand for answers, a representative answered
that "irreconcilable security concerns" regarding
Earth had come up, and forced them to make
this decision.
A representative of Marshall, Carter, and
Dark, Ltd somehow gained access to the personal
contact information of the O5 Council's members,
and used this information to reach out to
them with a business off.
The company is ordinarily on unfriendly terms
with the SCP Foundation due to their conflicting
interests, namely Marshall, Carter, and Dark's
interests in acquiring and selling anomalous
items, entities, and experiences to the highest
bidder.
However, in this case, the company's representative
approached O5 council members with a mixture
of politeness and desperation, begging the
SCP Foundation to purchase large amounts of
the company's stock.
The forest known as SCP-4000 lost all of its
anomalous properties all at once.
Investigation revealed only a small parchment
note in the area's entryway, which read: "Good
luck!"
One of the most perplexing, and disconcerting
phenomena that occurred concurrently with
SCP-UBU's first appearance was what happened
to SCP-3008, the Infinite Ikea.
Though this sort of thing should have been
impossible, the Infinite Ikea was anomalously
purchased by some unknown entity, the Ikea
branding was stricken from the building, and
it was converted into an emergency shelter.
All of these occurrences combined to serve
as a warning: something big is coming.
And, indeed, it was.
SCP-UBU.
It appears to be impervious to most forms
of damage, including blunt force trauma, heavy-caliber
machine gun fire, temperatures of up to 1,600
Kelvin, artillery fire, and direct energy
discharge from other anomalies.
It did express some discomfort when exposed
to several simultaneous direct nuclear strikes,
but was not affected beyond that.
The only recorded instance of lasting damage
to SCP-UBU was on August 14, 2784, in which
the entity bit its left thumb, seemingly for
no reason other than curiosity.
After biting its thumb, the entity screamed
for seven days straight, then entered a month-long
crying fit.
Thirty years and fourteen days later, the
thumb had completely healed.
SCP-UBU stands at a height of 4.3 meters.
While an exact measure of its weight is unknown,
attempts at measurement during its brief time
in containment showed that its weight is at
least 15,399 kilograms.
Its exact anatomical composition is unknown,
but a superficial examination of the entity
indicates that its body shape resembles that
of a large, androgynous humanoid covered in
hairless white skin similar in texture to
that of a dolphin or small whale.
The entity has no eyes, ears, or nostrils,
but seems to still possess the ability to
see, hear, and smell.
Its only visible sensory organ, aside from
its skin, is a 0.5-meter-wide mouth, humanoid
in nature, with a prehensile tongue of unknown
length.
On its lower body, it has no apparent features
aside from a cloaca that it uses to dispose
of waste.
SCP-UBU is prone to vocalizations, mainly
screaming, laughing, and babbling, but it
does not appear to understand speech in any
known language, nor does it seem to be attempting
to communicate with anyone it encounters.
Its primary interest appears to be destruction,
and causing as much of it as possible.
It will attack anything that it can get its
hands on, but seems to show a particular preference
for attacking and consuming human beings in
large, populous areas such as cities.
Its demeanor is both sadistic and childlike,
and it has been seen playing with its victims
for hours before moving on to a new target.
Due to the regenerative effect present in
SCP-UBU's vicinity, it is incapable of causing
permanent damage to any living thing, and
seems to have no greater motivation beyond
causing fear and pain.
SCP-UBU is classified as Tiamat, meaning that
it cannot be reasonably contained at this
time with the resources that the Foundation
has.
Therefore, the focus has shifted from containment
to neutralization, which is ongoing via Project
Beluga.
Any and all non-critical resources will be
funneled into Project Beluga, as neutralization
of SCP-UBU is a top priority.
Additional information on neutralization efforts
is restricted, and may only be accessed by
members of Project Beluga.
But in the end, it won’t be Project Beluga
that defeats this monstrous creature.
It’ll be the staunch efforts of one extremely
dedicated researcher…
Now check out “The O5 Council Must Die SCP-001
- The Way It Ends - Ouroboros Cycle” and
“Insane SCP-001 Fight - Gate Guardian VS
Scarlet King!”